a una hora de viena se encuentra la
central nuclear de zwentendorf única en
el mundo aunque está completamente
terminada nunca se puso en
funcionamiento
aquí abajo está el reactor dyn se puede
ver el interior pero normalmente el
tanque estaría encerrado con una tapa
que cubriría el reactor
en 1978 todo estaba listo para su
apertura pero los austriacos le dijeron
no a la energía nuclear en un referéndum
por ello la central permaneció cerrada y
ahora ofrece a los visitantes un viaje
en el tiempo aquí estamos en la antigua
sala de control de la central eléctrica
todo sigue en su estado original
y nos transporta a los años 70 al
quedarse sin su función principal la
central tuvo que reinventarse a lo largo
de los años
aquí durante tres décadas
todos los proyectos emprendidos
fracasaron una central de gas que no era
económicamente viable un museo de
tecnología que salió mal que los
propietarios no creían
hoy en día se utiliza como centro de
formación para el desmantelamiento
es seguro practicar el desmantelamiento
de las centrales nucleares después de su
cierre porque aquí no hay radiación la
central debía proporcionar electricidad
a 17 millones de hogares y también
desarrollar la economía de la región por
lo tanto el resultado del referéndum fue
un shock para los habitantes pero
cuarenta años después germán quit drive
alcalde desentender durante 27 años no
se arrepiente
aquí había unos 200 empleados
y obviamente perdieron sus empleos
pero muchos de ellos fueron a otras
centrales de austria
hoy después de las catástrofe de
chernóbil y fukushima
difícilmente encontrarán a alguien en 80
endorfina que se arrepienta de que la
central no se haya puesto en marcha
gracias a los paneles solares la central
produce electricidad para 200 hogares un
gesto simbólico para subrayar el
compromiso del país con las energías
renovables en austria más del 75% de la
electricidad procede de energías verdes
con la hidroelectricidad en primer lugar
hay una decena de centrales
hidroeléctricas a lo largo del danubio
como la de floyd e naw al este de viena
esta central suministra electricidad a
casi 300.000 hogares según este experto
la energía hidroeléctrica es una
alternativa eficaz a la energía
hidráulica puede producir electricidad
durante todo el año hay algunas
variaciones pero son muy predecibles la
energía nuclear también es una energía
fácil de predecir
pero la hidroeléctrica tiene ventaja de
ser renovable local e independiente de
cualquier importación de combustible
austria tiene como objetivo que la
electricidad sea 100% renovable en 2030
orgullosa de este modelo viena ha tomado
la delantera en europa y la lucha contra
la energía nuclear amenaza con presentar
una queja contra la inclusión de la
energía nuclear en la lista de energías
consideradas sostenibles por parte de la
comisión europea este texto conocido
como la taxonomía cuenta con el apoyo de
francia la guerra en ucrania ha
reforzado la posición de austria a pesar
de que importa cerca del 80% de su gas
de rusia
la energía nuclear no puede contribuir a
la protección del medio ambiente es
demasiado costosa es demasiado lenta y
es una tecnología con grandes riesgos
hoy podemos ver como nuestra dependencia
del gas ruso está perjudicando a europa
y austria poniéndonos en peligro y
amenazando nuestra libertad por eso
tenemos que reducir esta dependencia a
salir de ella pero solo podemos hacerlo
con energía que se produzca en europa
con las energías renovables si esta
nueva taxonomía entra en vigor austria
presentará una queja
esta postura cuenta con el apoyo de las
asociaciones ecologistas que sin embargo
le piden al gobierno que haga más para
acelerar la transición ecológica del
país austria no tiene energía nuclear ni
carbón y demuestra claramente que
funciona pero no debe dormirse en los
laureles para proteger el medio ambiente
y preservar y proteger el medio ambiente
y preservar la naturaleza tenemos que
ahorrar energía simplemente tenemos que
dejar de calentar el exterior aislando
las casas renovando de forma inteligente
y utilizando aparatos eficientes además
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero han aumentado masivamente en
el sector del transporte desde 1990 por
lo que es urgente cambiar de ruedas
estas reformas son aún más necesarias a
los ojos de las asociaciones ya que el
país se ha comprometido a lograr la
neutralidad del carbono de aquí a 2040